We're going to make an app with
three different text fields.
Each embellishes text in
its own way as you type.
Our goal is to use delegates to create
many different customized behaviors
using just one view.
The first turns the words cat,
dog and fish into emojis.
The second sets the text color to
be a combination of color words
used in the text.
And the third is related to
a label which keeps a character
count as you type.
For all three, the text field
views themselves look the same.
They're used directly off the shelf
as written by Apple engineers.
The differences in their behavior
come entirely from delegates.
A delegate is an object that executes
a group of methods on behalf of
another object.
The ability to reuse views
without needing to subclass and
modify them is an important goal of all
graphical user interface libraries.
We want view classes to be used as is,
and then we want control and
model classes to have the freedom
to customize those views.
The delegate pattern allows for this.
Let's look at some
examples of view reuse and
customization in the apps
we use everyday.
Here in Safari,
you can see a text field that was
designed specifically for searching.
It has custom completion and
is often presented with a table
view of search results.
If we look in settings, we see a table
that uses the same view class as
the search tables, but they look and
feel pretty different and present
content in a different structure.
How does the delegate pattern
enable the same view classes
to serve such different functions?